the most pressing issue today is
basically social responsibility so we
have 20 people here that are social
entrepreneurs selected by the slab
foundation that try to combine social
responsibility and business so how can
we move towards a more responsible work
because it can be very romantic by
telling we have to change this origin
then what about the climate change what
about this but at the end of the day it
is the person with fighting or
struggling for a new system assuage or
for clean energy or for helping women
who are mutilated since birth these are
the basically the real issues that
nobody discuss so let's take our time
and do our things our mission in life
because our life is our mission having
more social responsibility in whatever
so the basic question is are we doing
enough to transform our life in our own
missions